[Music]
welcome voice activation required for on
November third access denied god of
thunder Prince of Asgard strongest
Avenger
let me try Bennett welcome strongest
Avenger Oh what for Ragnarok
with a pg-13 in theatres November 3rd
get tickets now
so much has happened since I last saw
you I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh and then I
went on a journey of self-discovery
[Music]
whoa you have no idea I love the goddess
of death is invaded house god oh I miss
this
and you and I had a flag race tonight
did I word now I want easily this in
sound right well that's true
as god is dead it will be reborn in my
image I thought you'd be glad to see me
near the stopper here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
at the old days
[Music]
surprise this'll be such fun
hi
he's a fighter
here we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
we're the same you and I'm just a couple
of hotheaded fools
yes saying I'll collect fire door like
water kind of like fire butthole like
raging fire so I like smoldering fire
[Music]
you
[Music]